do you ever get stuck do you ever get
stuck sometimes and I realize when I get
stuck it's because I'm afraid that's
usually the only reason I get stuck or I
I and because a lot of times I think
when when we get stuck for me what when
you said stuck I thought like just
creatively stuck and yeah I think almost
all the time like when you're stuck it's
like an intersection of of lack of
information and fear and those things
cross and then that stuck and then for
me I've noticed that like there's this
writing mentor that I I love very dearly
his name is John voir house he writes a
lot of these books about creativity and
like what that you know kind of like
mentally what's going on in the brain of
a creative and almost nine times out of
ten when you're stuck it's because you
are at an intersection of lack of
information and fear and so when I when
I get stuck and a lot of times like I I
try to be very like almost like
scientific about my writing process and
I like to like measure my goals and like
how many pages did it right today and
things like that and I try to be very
measurable about it so I can because I
love to feel progress so whenever I
don't feel progress I have sort of a
mini freakout and then I start to
realize oh it's because I for this
creative problem I don't have enough
information or I'm scared and so and one
of the best things to do to alleviate
fear is to at least for me because I'm
obsessive compulsive I I make lists
so I list things so for instance like if
I'm having a difficult time figuring out
what happens next in a in a script of
mine I'll sit down nothing like okay
well the answer is here I just can't see
it right now so what I need to do is I
need to study what is here and generate
enough information to just dislodge
something in my brain so I can move
forward so if it's like you know if it's
like okay I don't know how this
guy gets gets the lightsaber he's got to
get a lightsaber something okay well
where is he he's in a he's in a he's in
a building okay what kind of building is
it's an office building
okay well let's list everything that's
in an office building until we figure
out Oh like oh yeah I didn't realize
that office buildings have staplers in
them maybe he could take the stapler and
then staple this thing and then that
dislodges that and then boom the
lightsaber pops out boom solved that's a
terrible example but I've I've taken
that that sort of problem-solving angle
too getting unstuck and I've applied to
almost every area of my life
so for it says like there was a there
was a time where I was like really
frustrated because like I really wanted
to get like more more screenings of my
film on the books right and and then I
had a moment I was like oh well I can
just sit here and make a list of all the
places in the world that might be
interested in screening my movie and you
do that and you keep going and you will
end up with a list that is absurd
absurdly long and then that sort starts
to take away fear because I think fear
comes from a mindset of scarcity and so
when you realize and you sort of take
your eyes off of that and look at the
abundance there's opportunities there
are solutions there are for me I'm a
comedic filmmaker so there are jokes
there all that is everywhere it's
everywhere and it's all just a matter of
focus and attention so if you're scared
about something and there's no shame and
being asked being afraid because fear is
a very real thing but what I try to do
is I just try to take a systematic
approach to alleviate my fear I try to
identify what it is and I try to solve
it like a like a math problem
you